[음악]
bsn 같이 성장해 나갈 파트너를
모집합니다 bsn 교육 중계 건물
관리 건물 설계 시공 등 자체적으로
운영하고 있고 중계만 아니라 빌딩
개발에 대한 모든 것을 배울 수
있습니다 또한 업무를 하면서 금융 율
세무 영역까지 협력사가 있어서
업무하시는는데 도움을 받으실 수
있습니다 bsa n 대한민국 최고의
부동상 기업을 뛰어넘어 글로벌 기업이
되기 위해서 매일같이 도전하고
있습니다 경력이나 학력은 중요하지
않고 저희와 같이 꿈을 잃어 가실
분이 지원하셨으면 좋겠습니다 저희
bsa 고객한테 가장 신뢰를 줄 수
있는 중개사가 되는 방법을 배웁니다
확실한게 아니면 중계하지 않고 아무
매물이나 중계하지 않습니다 그리고 그
수입 같은 경우에도 중계도 영업이다
보니까 한만큼 돈을 법니다 무조건
이회사에 있으니 억대 연봉이 될 수
있다라는 거는 다 거짓말입니다 진짜
억대 연봉이 될 수도 있고 아니면
마이너스가 될 수 있습니다 그건 다
본인하기 나름이고 저희 bsn 그래는
최대한으로 효과를 발휘할 수 있게
도와주는 그런 역할을
합니다 원래는이 빌딩 시장 자체에
관심이 많았었는데 독보적으로이 빌딩
시장 안에서 회사를 운영하시는 김윤수
대표님을 보고 좀 선택하게 됐습니다
대표님 영상을 보시면은 되게
진중하시고 되게 진실된 모습이 많이
보이잖아요 그 어떤 중개 법인들 다
그런 모습이 가장 잘 느껴져서 저는
bsnl 선택하게 되었습니다 입사를
하게 되면 약 한 달 정도의 신입
교육 기간이 주어집니다 기본적으로
입지 분석이라는 자료 분석
능력이라든지부터 제까지 배우고 나서
실무를 보고 있습니다 건물 매매를
위해 회사에 입사한 사람들이다 보니
건물 매매를 잘해 드리기 위해 필요한
기초 지식들을 전부 배우는 거
같습니다 일반적인 회사보다는 자유로운
분위기가 형성이 되어 있습니다 외부
미팅도 많고 부동산을 보러 다니기도
하고 런 환경에 놓여 있다 보니까
자유로운 분위기 속에 있는 거
같습니다 여성분들이 많은 편이시고
하지만 남성 분들께서도 다 비슷한
연령대라 의사소통에 전혀 문제가 없고
또 불편한 부분이 전혀 없을 정도로
너무너무 만족하며 다니고 있습니다
유튜브로 좀 보신 분들은 아시겠지만
정말 그 유튜브에서 보셨던 이미지랑
그 제가 회사 생활을 하면서 같이
지내면서 느꼈던 이미지가 정말
동일하네요 진취적이고 정말 그
꾸준함에 많이 배우고 있는 거
같습니다 아무래도 트렌드를 빠르게
습득하는 것이 큰 장점이지 않을까
싶습니다 젊은 사람들의 발걸음이
몰리는 곳에 돈이 몰리고 업무를
투자하시는 분들은 그런 곳에 투자를
하시기를 원하시기 때문에 트렌드를
빠르게 캐치하는 능력을 가지고 있으면
건물을 매 매입하시나요
있지 않을까 하는 생각입니다 일반
회사를 다니시는 분들 같은 경우에는
큰 변동은 없지만 꾸준한 월급을 좀
받잖아요 근데 이제 공인중개사 같은
경우에는 직업 특성상 급여의 편차가
좀 존재를 하는데 그 상방이 열심히
하는만큼 좀 열려 있다는 거 자체가
저는 매력이라고 생각을 합니다 건물
매입에서 터 건설 시공 건물 관리
임대이 모든 일년의 과정들을 직접
경험해 보실 수 있
보죠 회사 분위기랑 대표님의 그
진취적인 열정 때문인 거 같아요 그런
모습들이 직원들한테도 계속 영향을
미친다고 저는 생각을 하거든요 저도
그런 열정을 가지고 꾸준히 좀 열심히
할 수 있었던 거 같습니다 사람들이
돈을 어떻게 버는지 궁금해서였습니다
부동산을 통해서 큰 돈을 번다고
글이나 오디오로 이렇게 되게 많이
접하게 되는데 도대체 그 사람들은
어떤 방식으로 사고를 하고 어떻게
투자를 해서 버 는지 생생하게 한번
경험해 보고 싶어서 공인중개사에
도전하게 됐습니다 아직 우리나라에는
해외 부동산 업체가 우리나라에 진출한
사례는 있지만 우리나라 기업이 해외
진출한 사례는 없습니다 그래서
bsn이 최초로 우리나라 기업이 해외
진출하는 그런 회사가 되었으면 좋겠고
한국인의 저력을 보여주고 싶습니다
저희 bsn 함께하실 분이 계시다면
이메일 주소로 소개서를 보내 주시면
되겠습니다
감사합니다
n